foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving storage Studio this is the Ramsay
show it's where we help you win in your
life specifically in your money your
work and your relationships I'm Ken
Coleman joined by my colleague The
Fabulous Jade warshaw representing some
killer specs today if you're just
listening you're going to have to get to
YouTube later to look at her glasses
they're they're all sorts of hot uh
amazing she's always bringing the uh
you're bringing you're bringing the
shoes you're bringing the glasses you
got the accessories going it's the
second day of spring we gotta like put
some peppers I got it I look at you in
the face and I got you I have enough for
both of us what do you call those
turquoise let's call them turquoise all
right very good let's call them that hey
we are here together for you this hour
triple eight eight two five five two two
five that's the phone number to jump in
five now uh it is that time of year Jade
it is March Madness now even if you're
not a basketball fan and you're not
full disclosure NBA oh you like the NBA
yes all right so college basketball is
way better uh but we won't debate that
but March Madness is is where these uh
64 college basketball programs qualify
for the NCAA tournament and it has taken
over our culture in that if you're not a
college basketball fan people still fill
out brackets in fact I I think this is
true I don't know if I can prove this
but it feels like the men and women who
know the least about college basketball
do the best in the office pool in the
brackets they just kind of randomly pick
out of 64 teams and they go oh this
sounds right so I thought we would do
our own March Madness Jade okay but
we're gonna look at tuition so we're
going to look at the sweet 16. now this
is the 16 teams remaining and uh if
you're not a basketball fan this fires
back up tonight Prime Time the 16
remaining teams will begin to play and
we'll get to the weekend and we'll be
ready for the final four okay now uh
we're gonna look at the 16 teams Jade
and uh I'm gonna lay these out first and
and then don't look at that yet okay
I've got a quiz for you all right so
here are the teams Alabama will be
playing San Diego State University
Creighton will be playing Princeton
Florida Atlantic University will be
playing Tennessee Kansas state will be
playing Michigan State Houston will be
playing Miami Xavier will be playing
Texas Arkansas will be playing UConn
that's University of Connecticut and
Gonzaga will be playing UCLA now of
those 16 teams Jake okay how many of
those teams represent colleges and
universities that the tuition is over
fifty thousand dollars a year 50 000.
how many of the 16 have a tuition of
over fifty thousand dollars I see your
husband Sam trying to help it's like The
Price is Right out there I I gotta
believe it's half half of them really
all right the answer is three oh only
three of the 16 but but this is
interesting to me they are no surprise
here Princeton I mean it's an Ivy League
school okay that makes sense those
people think they're smarter than the
rest of us so they charge you more I get
it it's the ivy league it's like buying
a Louis purse you know all right now
here's what's shocking
number two on the list I saw this Miami
I'm shookith now you are from the that
neck of the woods now Miami is a great
place to visit and live I would
University of Miami University of Miami
is only you ready for this yeah 300
cheaper than Princeton me thinks if you
went to Miami
maybe you overpay my mother my
mother-in-law went to University of
Miami I'm gonna tell her what you said
if you're paying 57 for Princeton I'll
tell your mother-in-law that
I mean first of all it's too much to pay
for Princeton I'll get in I'll get to
that in a minute I'm shook that there
that I didn't understand that they were
that close in all right ready comparison
here's a quick quiz that you can follow
along at home okay of the schools
Alabama San Diego State Creighton
Princeton Florida Atlantic Tennessee
Kansas State Michigan State Houston
uh Xavier Texas Arkansas Yukon Gonzaga
UCLA which is the cheapest I'm gonna
give you multiple choice is it okay
Arkansas
is it
Florida Atlantic University or is it San
Diego State University which is not
cheap it's not San Diego you are correct
and so now it's between Arkansas and
Florida Atlantic University is Arkansas
the one that's called Razorbacks yeah
okay very good then I'm not going to go
with them because they seem very popular
so I'm gonna go with Florida Atlantic
only because I've seen that school I
used to live by it tell her what she's
won James did I win it she won Florida
Atlantic University very impressive a
lifetime supply of Rice-A-Roni
yes uh so there you go all right so we
won't comment on who's going to win the
games do you have a pick did you do a
bracket now that I say we're not going
to come I don't even know what language
you're speaking right now we'll move on
also so let's look at the bigger picture
all right so we just set that up as a
fun way of looking at College tuition
which is increasingly Gone Bananas
tuition has risen meteorically as you
know the student loans attached to that
tuition have gotten crazy we have a
great documentary called borrowed future
please watch it you got to watch it all
right so here we go let's look at just
colleges across the country and does the
return
make the investment worth it this is the
million dollar question all right and I
mean million dollar question we're
talking trillions all right here we go
most expensive tuition in the country
USC University of Southern California
again to me it's all about the
environment The Branding is the Louis
purse actually better than
the purse you get at Dillard's I don't
know I I don't have a mid-sized brand I
mean does it matter what you're majoring
in yeah that's a better question who
cares if you got a Louie purse do you
have a purse that works hey come on come
on all right most inexpensive again we
said Florida Atlantic
um
cheapest private school is Grand Canyon
University most expensive public school
is a University of Virginia and again
I'm from Virginia huh but they think
they're better than everybody else up
there in Charlotte I'm just gonna tell
you it's got some Sizzle Factor right
okay so this is what's going on the
point that I'm making Jay is when we
look at return on investment I would say
that no one and I mean no one including
your employer truly cares a great deal
about where you got your degree they
care about can you do the job what say
you I've never ever my husband Sam and I
were talking about this last night I've
never ever been asked for my degree yeah
ever yeah ever right
and who cares sometimes you're a mama
yeah you just moved to this area I'm
guessing you guys have got the doctors
for the kiddos you got the pediatrician
that's a big deal yeah did you think to
ask your pediatrician about their
medical training I just looked to see to
say MD next to their name you are such
an irresponsible mother I said you
wanted to say ashamed of yourself how
come you didn't ask that pediatrician if
they went to a really awesome school I
looked more at their years of experience
I looked more at their uh other things
okay very good point
nobody cares if you gotta have the piece
of paper by the way two-part question to
absolutely be sure is it the only way if
you're gonna be a doctor or lawyer is
two examples it is the only way you got
to get the degree sure nobody cares they
just don't care you'd be better off as a
lawyer going to the cheapest Law School
in the country okay and spend that money
on some nice looking suits because
that's what they're gonna hire you for
if you went to a big time law school and
you're broke and you shark skin
look like a skis they're not gonna
these are the facts coming up Jade
warshaw Ken Coleman the Ramsay show here
for you to take your calls don't move
Transformations around the corner
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and next week's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today a and
set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsay
[Music]
the Ramsey Show continues thrilled to
have you with us America we're here to
help you win
with your money and when you talk about
winning with money it's not just about
the budget
and just killing debt you got to
understand that if you're not
winning with the money
you're probably losing relationally oh
and uh you might not be doing your best
professionally it just impacts
everything Ken Coleman Jade warshaw with
you the phone number to jump in is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five so on this program we do talk about
relationships we do talk about work and
uh and I'm the work guy in other words
if you've heard Dave talk about getting
that bigger shovel to get out of debt or
to fill that emergency fund faster
that's the area that I focus and I got
to tell you something folks uh I've been
a Ramsey personality now for uh I think
four or five years and very excited to
announce uh I'm coming out on the road
it's a solo tour no backup singers Jade
you know and it's a little
nerve-wracking I know yeah but I gotta
get out there and uh this event is for
people who feel stuck professionally and
financially and what I mean by that is
you know the baby steps you've been
checking in on the program but you feel
like you need to make more money or you
want to start that side hustle uh or
you've been overlooked for promotion and
you're just feeling stuck suck that's
why we call the event breakthrough and
I'll be speaking on the formula for
courage so that you can actually break
through and then I'll be taking
questions live from the crowd Kansas
City Missouri April 20th that's coming
up that's the earliest date uh Chicago
May 16th Atlanta May 18th I'll be at
that one you're gonna come without I'm
going to come to the ATL one well then I
want you to sing uh we got to talk about
that no backup singers no no I'll get
out of the way oh okay you're just gonna
be solo it's gonna be a bonus content
all right uh and then Dallas Texas May
23rd uh everybody that buys a ticket uh
at ramseysolutions.com events gets my uh
very popular get clear career assessment
that will help with the Breakthrough
process we have VIP tickets uh where
I'll meet with folks beforehand spend
some time with you
um and uh these are fun smaller venues
because you know we've talked about this
I just want the energy yeah and I want
intimacy where everybody's together
they're trying to make progress in their
financial and professional life can I've
seen you in this environment and in your
element
um you know some of you know the
Building Wealth tour we've done and
beforehand you've done something very
similar where it's just a small group
and you're really meeting the people
where they are it's I can say it's
powerful thank you it's it's electric in
there so I you know only a couple
hundred seats at each of these so don't
wait because they're gonna sell out but
I'd love to see it Kansas City Chicago
Atlanta Dallas all the details and you
can get your tickets at
ramseysolutions.com events so uh let's
get to the phones shall we don't forget
to jump in for Jade and I we are here
for you triple eight eight two five five
two two five Jordan is joining us in my
old stomping grounds the ATL Atlanta
Georgia Jordan how can we help
get my call I will be there at that at
that event oh oh great career question
bro that's a great question I just love
me some Uncle Kenneth
I just got a new moniker Uncle Kenneth
I'll take it I'll take it I can't wait
to high-five you there Jordan how can I
uh and Jade help today
okay so I'll cut to the point I'm
engaged to be married I'm 24 years old
and uh she wants she's she's looking to
get her dream car okay what is the dream
car I know
it's a Toyota Tundra no Toyota Tacoma oh
okay new or used
uh whichever way we can get it so we're
we're thinking used okay that's a good
that's a very good starting spot all
right is there anything else you want us
to know about this
yeah I mean so we're debt free and we
are
I believe we are a baby steps
millionaires in the making and we have
yeah I think everything is laid out
and uh we have no debt
how much do you have saved
we have okay so here's the doozy we have
20K saved in like a combined savings
account okay uh and uh she loaned out
about 13k to her mom her mom's paying
that back
uh okay okay now back every month and
then I'm currently liquidating a crypto
investment of 30 000. okay that's okay
so uh you're right now your fiance's got
like 7K to her name and you've got 30k
um here's the thing I I have more
questions about uh your income and that
sort of thing and what sort of car that
you drive however when is the wedding
because okay you're not gonna buy
a car with her until you're married
that's that's my first piece of advice
to you
okay cool
um I am finishing I'm currently
finishing school
um she doesn't want to she she said
we're not gonna take any homework into
this marriage so she's like I love this
school right finish school and then
we'll go ahead and get married
uh we're gonna do this we're just gonna
do the courthouse thing okay so when is
that
whenever I graduate school Kim when is
oh sorry yeah that should be this summer
oh so like May
you're done in May uh no
no summer school
summer school okay so July
sure okay so I stick with my first
thought which is if she's willing to
wait until you guys are married and you
can start pulling together some money
here's the thing I wait till you're
married and then make sure you're
keeping aside three to six months of
expenses
um
what is the plan work wise because if
you're not like in your real job and all
that kind of stuff I'm gonna ask you
guys to get six months of expenses which
it you know might eat into what you've
got here the 30k uh with her 7K 37 that
might be be your emergency fund and so
from there you're gonna have to save up
to buy cash for this Tacoma
is she up for that that
cash life yeah
so that's funny because I come from a
family we all just we all Drive used
cars
um her family's a little bit different
they take out some loans so she asked me
yesterday she's like so uh what are your
thoughts on taking out a loan on this oh
boy all right so now this is where I
gotta jump in here because that's what I
was wondering is she is she pressuring
you to go get a new car to start this
new life together we're in the Atlanta
area uh are you because I used to live
there so I know my way around what area
of Atlanta
terrible Kennesaw okay great so here's
the deal I just did a quick search on
the Google I'm sure you're familiar with
this and uh I I want to just give you a
kind of a range here we've got a used
2020 Toyota Tacoma only 26 000 miles
that's low miles Jade the sticker price
on that at uh World Toyota uh as a local
lot 39.99
all right that's too much yeah now we've
got a used 2021 Toyota Tacoma with only
9 400 miles so I'm giving you I'm
getting real close to New but not quite
new all right this is 47.9 no no what
song you got for that they got curse
words um yeah it's gonna burn for me to
say this yeah okay so okay so now
you start you start going down let's go
to a used 2016.
Toyota that's what I'm talking about Ken
47.5 wait what 47.5 miles sorry 47 000
okay and now that's 29 so we're still
looking at
30 000
for a seven-year-old Tacoma slightly
under 50 000 miles I'm just saying
Jordan we're gonna have to listen to
Jade because we're saving up you know
we're not going to tell you it's okay to
buy a new one there's another piece to
this equation Ken um and YouTube Jordan
well it might not it depends on your
income because we don't want your
vehicles to be any more than half of
your annual take-home pay so that's why
I kind of said it depends on what jobs
you guys are in because if you're coming
out of you know what do you expect to
make when you get out of school and
you're into your job
yeah so uh I am currently the the a GM
at HoneyBaked Ham oh I love me some
honey baked ham
yeah you should stop by when you're in
Atlanta no you can bring one to the
event I'll eat it afterwards what's the
pay for that Jordan
I make 56. okay so you're making 56 and
then what does your fiance expect to
make
uh she is finishing up a test right now
and she'll be making 26 an hour okay so
between the two of you you guys have got
forty thousand dollars that you can
spend on vehicles so 20 each that's not
a Toyota Tacoma unless it's like oh wait
wait wait I got one
I used 2005 Toyota Tacoma two-wheel
drive 198 300 miles 8 400. that's what I
would pick that's what I'm saying that's
what I would pick hey sweetheart I got
you a really old truck to start our life
it's only eighty four hundred dollars at
the dream car I love you yeah I mean why
not right
hey man I'll see you in Atlanta Jordan I
appreciate you and don't forget to bring
the ham but the rest of you hang on more
of your calls coming up this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
good
[Applause]
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
Shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed Perfect Fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
helping you win with your money this is
the Ramsay show on Kim Coleman joined by
Jade warshaw we are here for you the
phone number to jump in is triple eight
eight two five five two two five triple
eight eight two five five two two five
let's go to Louisville Kentucky where
Kelly awaits Kelly how can we help
hi thanks for taking my call
um I was calling because we just got a
letter in the mail my husband's
grandmother had passed away last year in
March and we didn't actually know about
it until January because we weren't um
close to her really but
um we got a letter in the mail yesterday
that's asking or that's
um explaining an option to get a advance
on The Inheritance my husband is one of
the arista's um the estate but we know
that it wouldn't be a lot but I just
thought this was really odd you know
it's not like some you know basic letter
to just anybody like it's it's you know
has his grandmother's name his name so
it's directed to him specifically but
we've just never heard of it
um so I didn't know if you guys had any
insight as to what it could mean or what
it could be so when you saw the letter
your radar kind of went off
that this might not be are you thinking
maybe it's a scam
or um maybe not that it's a scam but you
know anything that usually happens fast
is usually not you know the best option
all the time so it just seems kind of
one of those things that might be like
too good to be true sort of thing yeah
what happened when you did you call the
number or did you contact the law firm
no I didn't fall because I um I asked um
my mother-in-law if she had received it
and she had never you know
um she hadn't heard anything and my
husband's brother and sister they hadn't
said anything apparently either but I
just thought that it was it was
odd what I would do um I've not heard of
I've not heard of in advance
um that doesn't mean it doesn't exist
I've just not heard of it what I would
do if I were in your shoes today is I
would uh research the law firm first and
find out if it's a real thing in a real
place and if there's any phone numbers
on it I always Google the phone numbers
to make sure they're not scams and are
they requesting any money on your are
they requesting any money from you
no it says though
um it says that they can advance a
portion of your inherent inheritance
directly to you within one to two
businesses I don't like it I don't like
it I don't like it either I would uh
whatever your initial letters were and
that situation I would go back to those
letters and call and say hey I'm
receiving this did this come from you
and again the the one that we think is a
scam I would just do your due diligence
on it I would Google the numbers Google
the law firm I don't like that like you
said it sounds like a scam to me
um but you did have a family member that
passed away but that's also public
records so anybody could scam on that so
I think you just have to really do your
due diligence it's good that you're
getting together with your family and
everyone else and kind of running this
by them hey did you get this and that
sort of thing but uh find out you know
who's in charge the executor of this
will in this estate and that's really
who you want to talk to about all of
that stuff and not uh a scammy letter
that you received in the mail you know I
it's it's most fishy to me Ken yeah I
thought there maybe there was a an
attachment to that with the Nigerian
prince request yeah remember that email
that went around oh yeah a long time
yeah it's it's quacking like a duck so
I'm thinking it's a duck yeah I agree
thank you so much for the call Kelly uh
you got a lot of wisdom just proceed
with that wisdom let's go now to
Philadelphia Pennsylvania the city City
of Brotherly Love John is there John how
can we help
hey how you doing we're loving life what
are you doing uh we're same thing
um quick question for you guys I have
about 130
000 in cash
um like 215 401K 550 equity in the house
um recently just laid off from my job oh
I'm so sorry yeah it's okay yeah stuff
happens Corporate America
um
but about 61 000 in student loan debt if
we pay off do we pay that student loan
debt off if we do that leaves us with 12
months of Reserves
for everything else
okay because the 130 was about two years
of savings
uh 130 was about a couple years because
we renovated our house and we paid off
another 65 000 in that time so we
probably
before we go so let me just ask real
quick what are your job prospects what
are you doing because before we walk
through this breakdown I want to know
what your income situation could be and
what you want it to be
um that currently works now she makes
about 75 000 a year and I was making
around 115 120. all right and so what
are you actively looking for something
in the same uh industry with the same
earning potential
um
maybe maybe now I'm trying to maybe
revamp my life and try to do something
totally different
okay and and what do you have an idea
I'm not trying to put you on the spot
but I mean what I'm looking at here is
is what are what is your realistic
income possibilities in the days ahead
and then what should it be in light of
this question
um digital marketing okay in that area
so somewhere maybe around 80 000. okay
do you have the qualifications for that
kind of work now or do you have to go
get that I do I do have a side house
where I own my own uh magazine company
so I have that feel I just haven't
really kind of as a hobby that I'm
turning into a business so I'm kind of
going that route yeah well the reason I
ask this is because I'm always thinking
about the bigger shovel right the the
income as David said for decades your
income's your greatest wealth building
tool and it becomes a wealth building
tool after we get everything cleaned up
and so I'm asking all those questions
really for you Jade to go all right
based on where he's at yeah I'm a little
cautious myself uh while they're not
struggling and they've been very
disciplined I kind of lean towards I I
want him holding off on that until he
gets a a steady stream of income what
are your thoughts uh initially I would
say that but my my first question is are
you able to sustain your lifestyle on 75
000 which is your wife's income like are
you able to live off of that without
pulling additional money out of your
savings
um
it would be rough you know I am going to
be getting Severance you know at the end
of April but you know that's some type
of income not sure yet but you know 75
000 is really
not that much money so
okay it would be would it be a little
bit of a struggle but it could be done
okay short term not long term then
here's here's a couple of options for
you because
um I think I mean you've got plenty of
savings like you've got more than a year
so there is money there that's at your
disposal and you can still keep like a
pretty hefty emergency fund if you feel
like you know we can mostly live off of
my wife's pay if I just add a little
supplemental something to it to make
that happen which while you're in your
in between time it can't hurt to still
find ways to bring in income I think
um if you I think you can pull this off
yeah um typically if there is a job loss
and it was really catastrophic we would
tell you to pause your baby step but
this doesn't feel as catastrophic you've
got a lot of cash laying around I I I'd
probably go ahead and pay off the the
student loan and then if I'm you I'm
finding ways to pull in a couple of
thousand dollars a month just couldn't
agree making it work I wanted to make
sure I heard your take on this because I
we want to work the baby steps is always
the answer but here's the deal it's not
catastrophic but I guess
I'd pay it all off but I would also be
working yes like I would not be waiting
on a severance I I would be replacing
the income while I'm figuring out what
my professional future looks like so
that's why I'm okay with you knocking it
all out yeah uh it's also gonna light a
firework it's gonna light a fire because
once you see that 61 000 leave that
could be the spark that's like all right
came on and you know what I don't want
and I'm not saying that you're going to
do this John but what I don't want is
you to rely on that really Hefty savings
account because that's not a that's not
an emergency you're able to work and I
get that's my concern I want you to pay
off the loans today yeah but I want you
working and not relying on what is now a
really robust baby step three emergency
it's quite robust several years there so
Good by the way good job you've done a
great job
um with managing your money so far very
very very good
pay it off today like don't sit there
and discuss it knock this dead out of
your life is a game changer and get to
work
let's not touch that amazing emergency
fund and boy you all are gonna sleep a
lot more soundly I think I know that's
right very good job when you manage your
money right you've got options
you really do I love it you can buy
glasses that look as cool as Jade's you
can wear the shoes that she wears
because how much debt did you pay off
Jay a 460 000 but the glasses only cost
me like ten dollars let's be honest
because you kept the discipline but you
retained the flare I did I love it she
shade warshaw I'm Ken Coleman and this
is the Ramsey Show don't move
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show we're
helping you win with your money which
means you're going to win in your
relationships and your work I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by my colleague
Ramsey personality Jade warshaw and if
you're a new listener or viewer and
you're trying to figure out all this
language and what does it mean baby step
this and baby step that what what do I
just I'm I'm interested but I need to
know more we've got you covered go to
ramseysolutions.com and click on the get
started button and just a very brief
question there to kind of see where you
are financially and we're going to get
you plugged into all of this so you know
where you need to be and what you need
to do that's ramseysolutions.com and
click on get started let's go north of
the Border Calgary Alberta Canada a
place I've wanted to go I've yet to make
it you've been all over the world have
you been there no it's too cold
well we shall see what David says David
how can we help
I can indeed pleasure to talk to you
yeah are you guys now is it too cold for
Jade to come visit Calgary
yes it's cold it snows here it gets to
minus 40.
you've heard enough I'll never be going
I'm crossing that one off the list okay
all right well how can we help you while
you shiver
well I'm 25 my wife is 24. we're
technically on baby step number seven
whoa set or have kids nice I said no
house
no house no house no kids yet that means
you're super relaxed and rested I I
assume that's right
sleeping we are wondering if it would be
a good idea or what your thoughts are on
taking six months off to travel in a
year's time
that sounds fun I love the fact that
you're taking advantage of the no kid
and no like not tied down by a mortgage
life that and they're 25 and 24. I feel
like this is the right time your knees
are good you can I climb I gotta ask a
question here are when you say take off
do you mean not working at all or will
you be do the digital Nomads that I talk
about on the Ken Coleman show all the
time what do we mean
uh not working at all but hopefully it
would turn into that digital Nomad like
style okay so what do you do now and and
what is it presuming that you would be
able to jump right back in with the same
company or the same type of work what
are you thinking
yeah I would be able to jump right back
in with my company so I work for the
federal government and they would allow
me to take the six months off and then
jump right back in well I don't have any
professional red flags Jade so you'd be
jumping back to baby step three because
I'm guessing you'd have to pause your
investing since no money is coming in
um how much do you have saved for baby
step three and then how much have you
saved for the six months of travel
so we currently have I have 30 000 in my
work pension we have 40
000 in our tfsa
and then we have 20 000 in our fully
funded emergency fund and then we'd be
over the next year saving up around an
additional 20 to 25 000 to go for the
six months
okay all right
um
here's
here's where I would just be very
careful I think if if all these numbers
pan out and you've got the 20 000 for
your emergency fund that's great you're
not going to have to touch that really
plan this trip out because I
I find that traveling is always more
expensive than you thought it was going
to be it's very easy to go over a budget
it's very easy to think oh we'll just
we'll just eat these types of meals and
then you get in the moment and it's like
oh we have to try it there's so many
things to do and try when you're
traveling
um so I want you to be very
um diligent about creating this budget
and then I want you guys to like swear
up and down we do not touch the
emergency fund because when you get out
there and you're in Italy or wherever it
is that you're going and and it's just
come on let's just go do that one it's a
helicopter ride we have to do it you
only live once it's going to be easy to
go over what you've planned so just if
it takes more time for you to save up
more money so you can truly do all the
things that you want to do I'm not going
to lie 25k sounds a little lean for six
months now you might be like minimalist
Travelers Backpackers staying in hostels
that kind of thing
um
David what say you she brings up a good
point you sound like the guy I'm gonna
take a stab I don't like being wrong you
sound like the guy that's got this thing
planned out to to the Jade expectations
and that you guys aren't staying at five
star places am I right or am I wrong
you are right it would be a budget trip
for sure okay it's a backpacking type
deal okay and do you plan
do you have the Reserves like did you
plan in reserves that this is actually
more than what we're gonna need because
I want you to be there when you go
I would I would set the 25 as a minimum
and then plan to save as much as
possible because I have found that as
well okay traveling always costs more
than you think yeah so let's do that
it's like if you had a building project
you wouldn't save up just enough to get
it done you'd make sure you had plenty
of reserves just in case because one of
the things Sam and I travel we've been
up to over 92 countries there are so
many little things that pop up
reciprocity fees and things that you
didn't know you had to pay you got to
pay to use the toilet uh in Europe
really did you know that Ken I wouldn't
I'd find a bush
I don't think David is a Bushman I think
he is how do you do I think David is
from Calgary all right I think David
knows he has to take care of business
I'll leave it at that David I think you
do the trip man I think you guys have
planned this out yeah I think you're
very disciplined and I applaud you I
think you thought through every angle
it's gonna be fun and you made it
through Jake so I if you make it through
what she was thinking about I think
you'd do it I think you guys enjoy it
the only thing I would say is I like
taking Jay's advice and doing a little
bit extra because I don't think you
should make your wife stay in like a
really rough place unless she likes to
camp and that's outside I'm a 700 thread
count guy or higher I don't know what
she is but I I just you know yeah you
know what I mean making a great trip and
uh what a great experience that's fun
that's going to be a good time now you
said this earlier
and I want to bring it back to this
you know we talk a lot to people who are
trying to get out of debt this is a this
is the total other side of this okay but
when we we use terms like Financial
Peace and we say it a lot and I think we
miss
we miss the real Freedom part of that
yeah this is the example yes a 24 and 25
year old couple no house no kids yet and
they're gonna take six months and
they're gonna go travel the world I
gotta tell you
I think they're gonna be better World
citizens as a result of this and this is
100 what do you think their relationship
is going to experience as a result of
something like that I look I'm gonna say
this and some of you are might you know
get me in the comments that's fine a lot
of people do a lot of Yakety Yak Kim but
they never been anywhere people want to
talk about what's wrong with this and
what's wrong with that and I'm like go
travel I think go go see the word it
makes you so much more well-rounded it's
great for your relationships it's great
for your self-esteem because you
challenge yourself to do new things uh
you taste new foods you're around more
cultures it just it's really invaluable
and if you can do what our friends David
and his wife did and it doesn't matter
you don't have to be young to go travel
go travel in your 60s go travel in your
40s whatever but do travel and do pay
cash to do it because it is very
enriching it's a very important part of
uh life and what I think is happiness
because there's there's something that
happens when you see all the places out
there and then you come back to home
sweet home you have a different level of
appreciation it's absolutely contentment
it's and by the way you know Davis said
this for years you know don't bring your
vacation home with you in the form of
debt and this is another thing all the
things we just talked about plus why
you're there you go holy cow like we're
not working yeah we've saved up for this
we can go do what we want within this
freedom of this budget and you just are
allowed to truly be present people that
are that are strained and stressed by
debt have a hard time being present good
point I know there's a humanness here to
be um you know what
it's that exhale like okay we're doing
something really exciting at the early
part of our relationship and you can
truly soak in the moment you can truly
soak in the moment and I just it's it's
there's a
um a team building that happens with
that because like you said
she might be more of this 700 thread
count and he wants to sleep outside on
the grass in nature and you have to you
have to compromise and ex Let each other
experience those sides of each other and
then there's the money aspect she wants
to spend money on that he wants it's
worth it yeah and then you experience
those just amazing things together those
views those monuments it's just go
travel but do it in cash I love it oh so
good well listen we gotta get out of
here but before we do want to thank Jade
uh my co-host Jade warshaw she's amazing
I want to thank James and the crew and
you America for listening this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's Ken if you love the show and
want a deeper dive on your money Journey
we have a Weekly Newsletter that gives
you trending and helpful articles and
tips on following the Ramsey win go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio this is the
Ramsay show it's where we help you win
in your life specifically your money
that affects your relationships that's
involving your work and so we cover all
three of those areas because we want you
to have true Financial Peace and live a
life of purpose I'm kid Coleman join my
colleague Jade warshaw the phone number
to jump in this hour is triple eight
eight two five five two two five now I'm
a slight bit distracted those of you
that are watching the show can already
tell why I'll explain to our listening
audience in a moment
but uh we're gonna cover one of the
biggest budget Busters in the world Jade
I would say you think it's the number
one budget Buster I know it is you all
got she knows it is and you all do too
there's people listening what is the
number one budget Buster say it with me
food groceries eating groceries all the
things so for our listening audience
God
I'm struggling I'm struggling to focus
because of the smell wafting from this
board yeah we gotta set up here one foot
away from me you've got fries and
ketchup and then I if I if my eyes don't
deceive me I think I see some Oreos yeah
and double stuff but don't don't look
too closely at those and I'm gonna set
up why is the food in here okay and
you're not gonna be able to eat it yeah
we're gonna eat it we're gonna eat in a
minute here's the thing we all know
food's the biggest budget Buster right
it is and you can save so much money I
didn't realize exactly how much until I
really dug in you can say between 20 and
60 percent can by buying generic brands
I feel like I have to be a voice of the
people here you're a man of the people I
I I try to be I feel like you're
probably right I know you're right about
that because I know you but I feel a
little
I feel a little bad about myself when I
grab the generic prints I'm looking over
my shoulder to see if any neighbors
recognize me am I the only one that
feels that way anybody in the studio
audience a little bit of Shame when you
grab the dinner thank you sir you're
there we go now some honestly why are
you ashamed okay I don't know I'm not a
psychologist I'm just revealing my
feelings I'm gonna pull these numbers up
and it's going to change your life this
is what I need because I want to get
over the shame of grabbing the generic
brand it's for some items we're going to
decide if it's worth it ketchup ketchup
that you buy every day okay you can save
60 percent
by buying the generic brand the the
national brand that we all know Heinz
and those things like that that the
price of 32 ounces of Heinz is 5.29 so
what brands do you have over there
because you got the bottle so Heinz is
the big culprit Heinz is 529. whoa then
you've got your Publix brand if you
listen Publix is like Kroger it's kind
of like a middle of the road yeah your
Kroger brand or your Publix brand 279.
so we've already gone down significantly
yeah and you're saying there's a cheaper
version yeah great value Walmart Walmart
baby well Sam Walton of course I should
have thought of that think about that
that's like a four dollar spread yeah
that's unbelievable just don't go to
Walmart after midnight so let's see Ken
wait should I set up the Oreos too and
then we'll just no no let's start with
the ketchup sorry because we just with
the ketchup so all right what do you I I
have three bowls of ketchup three bowls
it's a blind test taste excited so let's
see if you let's see if you know the
difference so where are the fries from
these are from the Ramsey Cafe just
downstairs just around the block
downstairs one of the great benefits of
working at Ramsey Solutions uh Dave by
the way Papa Dave subsidizes our lunch
everything thank you papa Dave we love
Dave okay so this is a Ramsay Solutions
fry yep and I'm gonna go left here go
left and I'll go right because I'm gonna
do this with you but you know what the
real answer is I don't remember
before I eat this what am I determining
which tastes best yeah tell me which
tastes best all right because you don't
know which is which
y'all can hear us chewing on the camera
on the on the radio all right I'm gonna
tell you I know you hate it I'm gonna
tell you right now what
I'm a Tang guy I want some tang in my
condiments there's a nice Tang in number
one let's go number two all right don't
be in here double dipping Ken
I don't know but I have to have a swig
of water to then clear out level uh
ketchup one ketchup two here we go
oh I got a little bit on my finger and
I'm not ashamed to lick it
all right let me taste I'm tasting your
one quick swig
oh no I don't like one one is very salty
okay don't try to influence me I'm
trying to be a man of people now this is
an exceptionally large fry and I like to
give bonus tips from time to time here's
what you do with this one you fold it
together look at that I got some people
out there that know what I'm talking
about you gotta make the scoop and look
at this now I've got it this is like you
wait you scooped the wrong side no I
didn't I went one two and this is three
I'm talking about your scoop technique
oh would you leave me alone
ooh
all right
what do you think one is the best
three is second the middle one is third
now reveal which one one is the best I
said that number one oh we're gonna lift
it up I don't want to choke and die go
ahead here we go three two one oh
hi hi
you chose the national bird I have a
sophisticated palette apparently but
here but I have a theory
I came prepared
let me tell you why I think I chose
Heinz why I said I like a little bit of
Tang I think that the big boy brands are
putting more syrups and sugars and stuff
in there and that's why they're charging
us more what say you well the real
question is is it worth paying three and
a half dollars no not at all but the
taste test is what it is so we prefer we
prefer the national brand but it it
could be worth is it worth three and a
half dollars no no no but there's a
reason why now let's get to the Oreos
Oreos so I'm just gonna this is gonna
just get one oh wow is this don't don't
read what it says on it just just I
think it could tell no no Oreos
the whole cookie come on now Ken
we gotta hurry yeah all right I'm gonna
taste one
all right
oh number two I can tell this is not an
Oreo but the the it's good though
okay I'm going number three James is
getting nervous about the clock that's
pretty close this is pretty good
all right we're gonna hit the groceries
it's pretty good this is pretty good
what do you think can I I I'm just
telling you guys right now I ate one
that I know is not an Oreo and is
banging I'm going number three the cream
is better number three number three
Publix brand this Publix cookie right
here is busting y'all don't know what I
don't know what that means but it turns
out your boys it's good I'm a Publix guy
man okay so let's see the prices better
let's see the prices on these cookies
Austin because I know the Oreo 420 420
4.20 cents for the Oreo then we come
down to the Publix brand that's the mid
brand 379 so we're saving about 50 cents
and some change there then we get to the
Twist and Shout come on Great Value come
on 268. you guys can't name that better
that's like a twisted shout feels like a
dollar 45. I'm getting back to the Twist
and Shout from Walmart yeah we just
saved you five dollars on just two items
think about it the average person's
probably putting about I don't know 20
50 items on their cart for a week think
about how much you would save if you
saved this much on every item you'd save
like eighty dollars per trip 80 a week
y'all we just gave you free game right
here I'm going public so you only live
once eat eat good tasting Nori this
Publix cookie it's in the middle it's on
point all right are we doing some meal
planning rules coming up are we doing
that yeah we'll do it we're gonna do
that you're gonna love it don't move I'm
gonna Clear My Throat
we'll be right back this is the rainbow
[Music]
foreign
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is budget
friendly biblically based Health cost
sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
C of chm could be right for your family
learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by my colleague Jade
warshaw we're here to answer your
questions about your life
specifically your money
your relationships and your work Triple
A
825-5225 uh Jade you are you are not
only a money personality here at Ramsey
Solutions an expert someone who's paid
off with your husband Sam almost a half
a million dollars in debt you've lived
this
but you're also a foodie yeah you eat
well you cook well and you know food is
when you first start to do your budget
that's where you start to see money
flying out the door whether that's
eating out fast food on the way home or
just not meal planning so yeah you have
a lot of good tips on this and I want
people who are brand new to this to go
wait a second I can start saving money
now with different purchasing choices
yes and I I want to highlight like Ken
said these are the things that I came up
with when we were in the thick of it
paying off debt trying to get through
this thing and a lot of these things I
still use to this day because they
actually work so number one I always say
Ken the meal plan is for your food what
a budget is for your money so a budget
obviously we know it instead you tell
your money where to go instead of
wondering where it went with the meal
plan it's the same thing you tell your
groceries what to do instead of finding
them where they went which is usually
spoiled in the trash right so this is
the meal plan I'm going to give you guys
eight ideas that you can Implement to a
day so that you can really start doing
this now let me caveat this by saying I
know happy y'all listening are like Jade
meal planning's not for me because I
don't even like cooking I'm just not
here for it trust me the way we're gonna
do it we're gonna make it for you okay
number one
and this is in order of importance I
might say you got to take inventory kid
because if you don't look and see what
you already have you're gonna buy things
twice you're going to buy more than what
you need so you look at and you you make
you look at what you already have and
you go okay I got this can of beans I
got this in here and you craft your
recipes based on what you already have
that's thing one don't just be out here
and say you know what Chinese sounds
good I'm gonna make some stir-fried no
look at what you have and say okay I've
got beans what can I make with beans so
take inventory first then you make the
menu and then you make the list and then
you shop in that order that's how it
must be all right now for those folks
who don't like to cook busy folks uh you
got a lot of kids you like got the
soccer practice all that cook for no
more
that's it I'm only asking you to cook
four times a week that's it but the key
here is
you got to cook things and double it up
so you have leftovers I love this I have
a tradition at our house where on Sunday
nights I love to grill you know when it
gets into the warm season and of course
I don't want to stop grilling yeah and
it's like the one thing I love doing
around the house that I have a great
attitude about is cooking so I'll cook a
ton of meat that's right because I got
three teenagers two of which are boys
and they have tapeworm and so you gotta
you gotta cook a lot of people eat a
whole chicken I like that idea yeah cook
for no more because and if you're not in
baby step two a lot of us it's like on
the weekend it's Friday night's the time
for pizza anyway so you don't need to be
cooking all this food you overcook then
you have it spoiling in the back of the
fridge all right number three few and
fresh is best everybody knows they got
that plastic tin of spinach they buy the
big one at Costco and then it rots in
the back so I say buy just a few fruits
and vegetables at a time right just what
you need for the week don't be trying to
buy it up in bulk all right learn to
love leftovers that's the next one Kim I
just gotta say it the people who say
um I don't like leftovers oh it wasn't
good to begin with oh I love it and that
was your problem uh all-time favorite
leftover dish for me spaghetti oh I was
gonna say lasagna all right we're right
why is pasta so good the next day make
it like
congeals and the sauce gets I don't know
it feels in the sauce see I never knew
that it it just comes together leftover
pasta if you don't love leftovers it's
because it wasn't good in the first
place which means you need to find
better recipes
next don't leave it freeze it oh oh
y'all are leaving a perfectly good broth
in the fridge you're you're leaving
perfectly good yogurt what freeze that
freeze it freezing broth when you make
soup and you know sometimes the recipe
calls for and there's that half a thing
left just put it in the same con you
don't have to put it in a tupperware put
the whole thing in it in the freezer
freeze it say I do the same thing with
my marinara there's leftover I put the
whole jar in the freeze marinara you can
freeze earthing Ken marinara tofu yogurt
coffee creamer you'd freeze a bologna I
freeze I'd freeze a bologna sandwich oh
my gosh all right you gotta stop you're
going too far no I'm not these people
need this dude do double duty do you
know what do double duty means Kim well
I gotta be careful here on how I answer
that because I raised three kids and
changed a lot of diapers so I went
another Direction with that double duty
for me was changing two babies at once
and I got pretty good at it can double
Duty just means don't I know I'm gonna
make this recipe with water chestnuts
don't nothing else call for water
chestnuts don't do that to yourself pick
recipes
that's what I'm saying you pick
ingredients that recipes that use the
same ingredients red sauce you can put
that in so many different things all
right and don't forget you can freeze it
you can freeze the cheese do you freeze
cheese yes yes Ken Coleman I freeze my
cheese all right there's no need to yell
at me I'm gonna hit one more ah stretch
for Success now this is what this means
stretch stretch and this is how we now
we're in a fitness segment I'm confused
it's when you have a little bit of
leftovers left but it's not enough to
feed the whole family oh no why don't
you tell you something don't do this do
it Ken Senior did this he did it with A1
Sauce my dad would make us eat steak
with A1 Sauce three extra times he would
put water in it no shake it up and then
diluted A1 Sauce now I say enough enough
I must stand for the people not that kin
oh I'm talking about keeping things on
hand that help you stretch meals things
like pasta you add pasta to it you add
rice to it you put it inside a tortilla
all right you get my point yes don't
dilute the sauce please no don't dilute
the sauce freeze it yes yes don't dilute
don't dilute I'm talking about adding
things and finally just save up a money
of cash so that you can buy things when
it's on sale
because you see it by buy one get one
free and you're like oh I want to tell
me about this the other day you said
that when yogurt goes on sale you go buy
it in bulk and then it's no surprise to
anyone who's paying attention she
freezes it you do because when yogurt
goes on sale you're usually it's either
BOGO or it's like a dollar off that's a
lot of money
tell you what I know folks Jade's a very
lovely person but if she would ever snap
on one of her family members disappeared
I'd check the freezer first
it they won't fit because it's all
filled up with yogurt
first it is there it is this segment
just got very real planning rules Jade
warshaw you can check her out on
Instagram she's doing all kinds of great
stuff at Jade warshaw that's right very
good and uh check out her glasses if
you're watching on YouTube or if you're
listening check it out on YouTube Just
Get incredible glasses all right let's
get a call in real quick uh will is on
the line in Boise Idaho will how can we
help
you there will
yes I am hello will we got about two
minutes so what's your question
so my wife and I are I just turned 21
she's about to turn 20 we're new to the
baby steps we just crossed over baby
step one into baby step two and about
six months ago I took a position as a
manager in a landscape company with that
they are offering a company rig to me
and they just opened up a simple IRA
that I could invest into with that
they're matching up to three percent of
whatever I put into it and my question
was is should I be investing into that
simple IRA at this age and if I sh while
I'm in baby step two and if I should
where should my investments go should
they be a little bit riskier because I
am young or should I just stay with the
crew and steady well let me lay it out
for you real quick in this next minute
so I love that you're asking this
question and I love that your employer
is offering a benefit like this at this
point in the baby steps it's not time we
don't start investing until baby step
four and at that point you would then
invest 15 into that IRA
um at three percent which is great
actually what I would do is I since it's
just a traditional IRA I would invest up
to the match and then I would invest the
rest of your money into just a Roth IRA
that you can open up on your own and
that's what I would do but I would wait
until baby step four to do it because
you need all of the money that you have
right now to throw out your debt
snowball and get clear of that so
hopefully that answers your question
will and not only that but when the time
to investing invest comes we always talk
about investing into four different
types of Mutual Funds growth growth and
income aggressive growth and
international so when the time comes
that's what you'll be doing you'll be
getting with the smart investor Pro and
making it happen yeah and we'll hang on
the line we're going to give you a copy
of The Total Money Makeover uh Dave's
Dave Ramsey's number one selling book of
all time just really a great guide for
the baby steps you're off and running we
want you to follow them in order because
there's a reason hang on the line we'll
give you that book thank you so much for
the call she's Jade warshaw I'm Ken
Coleman your call are standing by and
we'll be back to answer them very soon
don't move this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
a home is one of the biggest decisions
of your life you need a partner like
Churchill Mortgage Churchill is one of
the highest rated lenders in the country
and their Ramsay trusted because they do
what's right for you Churchill works
with you to build a mortgage the Ramsay
way one that doesn't bust your budget
sets you up for financial success and
helps you get out of debt faster go to
churchillmortgage.com today and get
started
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the Ramsey show where we
bring you hope filled advice to your
questions around your money your work
and your relationships Jade warshaw is
my co-host this hour I'm Ken Coleman
we're both Ramsay personalities and we
are here for you the phone number to
jump in is triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five five two two five let's
go to Salt Lake City Utah Andrea is
there is it Andrea or Andrea
it's Andrea oh good good good good well
how can we help
um I actually prepared my question for
Dave and didn't realize he was in today
but it's actually a good surprise
because this is a really great question
for you Ken so um great so he my husband
just took your course on Monday okay
from the the career assessment and I
just need to figure out the best way to
give him a gentle push to make a career
a career change
um after 15 years of doing the same
thing and absolutely hating it and not
making enough
um he's in his mid-40s he doesn't think
that he has any choices or options and I
think we do
um but I don't know how to help them see
that I mean this has been going on since
we've been married yeah and I just I
feel like I'm getting my head on the
wall yeah well you are and I I want to
set your expectations here
there's not a whole lot you can do to
help and I think you know that because
we're 15 years in you've tried to help
and gently push before I'm guessing yes
or no
yes okay so he took my get clear career
assessment which is great because at
least he's now got some self-awareness
did he talk to you about it and then if
he did what were the kind of things he
was saying to you
um well I mean it was it was great but
um
he said that it wasn't a whole lot of
surprise
because you know he knows himself pretty
well okay um he's not entirely sure
where to go because a lot of the options
require going back and getting more
education more training he is certified
as a project manager and that is on his
list
um and he's tried to switch careers to
that from the medical field but has not
had a lot of success with that
um okay so he tried and he got rejected
a few times is that about right yes yes
that's about right and he does not
handle rejection super well right so I'm
hoping that what is his name by the way
his name is Nolan Nolan I would love for
you to schedule a call with Nolan on on
my show
but I hope that you'll have Nolan watch
this on YouTube because Nolan I want you
to hear me say that you've tried to move
into project manager it's something that
you've identified as something that
you're good at and that you enjoy is
that right Andrea would you say he would
agree with that he enjoys it and he's
good at it
yeah he's doing it for his job already
just doesn't have the title exactly and
it's okay right but would you uh would
he jump at it if I handed him a project
management job that paid him 15 20 more
and he actually had the title and he saw
a ladder of growth beyond that would he
jump at that today or would he go I
don't know oh no he
no he fast um he needs to see a clear
okay
all right do you guys have kids
we do we have three did both of you
teach them to ride bikes or was Nolan
more involved
um he let's we kind of didn't teach them
we gave them balance bikes and they
figured it out on their own yeah okay
well it's gonna kill my metaphor but uh
here's the point uh if I was talking to
Nolan I'd say Nolan what would you have
said to your kids if they would have
come in after two or three attempts to
ride the bike and said I'm done I'm I
just don't think I'm ever ever gonna be
able to ride a bike what would he say to
that and the point here is is that he
has been rejected a few times and it's
interesting that when I said it that way
you jumped on that and said he hates to
be rejected and I just want Nolan I want
you to understand something so do I and
I'm fairly certain Jade you hate
rejection as well oh nobody likes it so
this is a human thing and and I will
tell you if you know what you want to do
and why you want to do it this is a get
back up on the horse and keep getting
after and I'm going to give you a couple
of tools and I love that he took the get
clear assessment and Andrea that he he
wasn't surprised by it so here's what's
going on with him
he doesn't have a self-awareness problem
he has a confidence problem
and he's dealing with a lot of
self-doubt and he's been dealing with it
your entire marriage which tells me he
was dealing with it before you got
married does this all seem to make sense
to you
um it does I've never thought of it that
way because he is pretty confident in
the things that like he knows he's good
at yeah um but he's not confident when
he has to take on new things so he's a
guy that probably naturally doesn't like
change uh likes things you know to kind
of be known and so he's just dealing
with he's been in one field for a long
time and he's begun to feel like he's in
a rut and when you're in a rut you're
kind of trying to move in and out but
you just stay stuck and he's not stuck
he's just full of doubt doubt that
he'll get a shot
and maybe doubt that he would do a great
job or maybe it's just a doubt that
he'll get a shot so
there is no magical thing you can do
other than having watched this
and I hope Nolan you hear me
cheering you on not guilt-tripping you
because what has to happen right now
Nolan is that you've got to say I want a
better life and in order to have a
better life
I've got to move out of this rut that
I'm in and I'm actually not stuck see
when you s when you're stuck you require
someone if your car is stuck in the mud
or the sand
which I've had happen to me growing up
in the beach area you gotta have
somebody pull you out
but he doesn't need you to pull him out
you know what he needs from you Andrew
he just needs
a loving and encouraging life reminding
him you are so talented at this you love
all the stuff that comes with project
management and that's the only thing you
can do you cannot push him anymore he
has got to get to the point where he
believes in himself and the only thing
that you can do in this situation is try
to transfer some of your belief in him
once he realizes that you believe in him
that you're not ashamed of him that
you're not frustrated at him that you're
not mad at him that you don't resent him
and by the way Andrea if you do yeah in
any of those areas you're not a bad
woman that's called that's just called
normal life but you've got to check
yourself at the door and make sure that
you're not coming across in any of those
ways because this is a guy
who's just down on his confidence Jade
that was a word Ken Coleman what you
what Ken said about stuck and needing
someone to pull you he doesn't work that
need to be pulled out he just needs to
walk out yeah walk on out I love that
that's that's for that's for all of us
Andrea not just not just you yeah so hey
uh listen hang on the line there's a
couple things I want to give him
um I want to give him both of my books
but I really want him to read the
proximity principle which is a deep dive
it's the first book I wrote here Jade
and this is a deep dive on how to turn
connections that's real people into
opportunities
here's what I know about getting out of
ruts and getting unstuck when I'm around
the right people Jade and I'm in the
right places
I've found and I'm guessing you have too
that the right time tends to just show
up yeah it does it does I don't recall
any major opportunity in my life and I
wonder if you have where you walked into
it as opposed to it found you no you you
have to get around the right people and
the right things and that they start to
transform you to be ready for what that
situation has to offer you that's right
but you know there's another lesson here
when I get around the right people
and I get around the right places I'm
not trying to be cute with that so don't
like don't miss the real truth behind
this there's intentionality and
diligence there I am intentional to go
who are the people I need to be around
yes what are those places that I need to
be in so that I can get some experience
have some conversations get noticed you
know have the opportunity to fail so
that I can learn and do it better next
time there is an intentionality behind
this and I just this idea that
that we're gonna just kick Doors Down is
is it's kind of been cartoonized I agree
and and and and movies have made it seem
and motivational posters which I find
most successful people they just keep
showing up around the right people in
the right places and then eventually the
right time happens I I 100 agree you've
got to stick around for the opportunity
to show up I think but you got to put
yourself out there that's the hard part
so I want to acknowledge like you're a
musician so I watch American Idol every
year with my kids and I'll tell you the
number one reason why I watch it
I'm so admire those singers that are
terrified yeah they're not quite sure
how good they are and then we all
discover they're really great but they
put themselves in that moment to be
discovered that's true and there was a
lot of work that went in before that
moment that nobody ever saw yeah which
is you know and just sheer guts I'm
gonna go stand in front of Lionel Richie
and sing his song that's good don't give
me don't get me started on Lionel Richie
now uh we don't have enough time for
that Ken Coleman I need to discover more
about that during the break I don't know
if that's good or bad we'll find out if
I need to tell you I will but hey
appreciate the call Andrea your
husband's a good man
and you're a good woman hang in there
encourage him encourage him encourage
him he'll jump out all right don't move
Jade warshaw Ken Coleman this is the
Ramsey show coming right back
[Music]
all right
welcome back America thrilled to have
you here on the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman and I'm joined by my colleague
Jade warshaw so excited that you're here
the phone number to jump in is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five well debt payments and
inflation are combining for Perfect
Storm they're stealing more and more of
Americans paychecks and we know a lot of
you feel like you're absolutely drowning
and you're scared to death
shouldn't have to live with that kind of
stress but if you want things to change
you've got to say I'm done I'm not going
to live this way anymore and I'm going
to do something different and that
different is Financial Peace University
it's our nine lesson course that'll
teach you how to beat debt and build
wealth
nearly 10 million people have taken
Financial Peace University and they will
tell you they don't have to worry about
money like they used to and I will say
this
when I when I get to co-host this show
on a weekly basis Jade and we do debt
free screams
I've not heard one debt-free screamer
talk about how inflation's got them down
they're just inflation proof they've
risen above it they don't they don't
have to worry about it and that can be
you so if you're done stressing about
money take control start Financial Peace
University now
by going to ramseysolutions.com
FPU that's ramsaysolutions.com
FPU all right let's go to Brent in Flint
Michigan Brent from Flint what's going
on hey how you doing I'm good how are
you guys doing we're having a blast
what's up
man appreciate taking my call
um I'll try and paint the picture for
you about four years ago my wife and I
we took financial piece
um and at that point you know we were
all on board uh we paid off Vehicles
paid off credit cards I paid off eighty
thousand dollars in student loans
um
so we were good um we had a mortgage we
were paying out the mortgage we paid
extra
um every
um you know every month we paid extra on
the mortgage to to you know bring it
down
um and then in August of 2021
um we made the decision to sell because
we both you know we wanted to be closer
to uh schools because we got three
daughters uh they're involved in
athletics you know we're running a dance
soccer basketball over the place in our
previous house we were about 15 20
minutes out of town so I figured it was
a good time to sell we sold
you there
did I lose you I think we lost Brent are
you there Brent One More Shot
well let me let me see if I can just
give him a quick little something if we
can't get you back my screen said that
you had 300K in savings my guess is it's
from the sale of the home so if you're
looking to buy another home just
remember the rule of thumb you've got to
have use a 15-year fixed mortgage that's
thing one and then we want to find
something where the the payment
everything in taxes Insurance all in is
no more than 25 of your take-home pay I
think yeah I think we got him back let's
see if we can get him Brent from Flint
are you there
yeah sorry about that no worries all
right so hit us hit us with your
question we've got a general idea
so we want we've been in an apartment
for about two years now two better
apartment three girls and a dog and it's
just been crazy and in terms of like a
home like do we wait until we find a
home that checks all the boxes or do we
you know purchase a home that isn't
necessarily what we want because you
know we just want to get out of the
apartment because Market wise we're
looking at a home of 300 000 home we
don't want a mortgage sure but yeah at
the same time I'm I'm paying 300 000 for
a home that's like 18 1900 square foot
well here's the thing um I see both
sides of it and I get your frustration
level you're you're at level 10 of like
explosion right now because you're in a
small place with kids yeah you're like
ready to just go off yeah I don't really
want you to make a decision based off of
that feeling because when you let that
emotion guide you that's when you end up
just let's just get something let's just
get whatever and um you're likely to
regret that
um the 300K that you have that's a
pretty uh decent amount of money there's
nothing in in Flint Michigan that you
can get that check off the boxes that we
talked about that I was saying while you
were
um getting your phone back uh is there
nothing there because are you trying to
do a
by Foley in cash or are you trying to
just have a nice down payment for what
you want
so yeah we set a budget we don't want a
mortgage and we figured you know 300 000
is a it was a good amount
um to pay for a home cash we did find a
home
um and we actually you know we did put
an offer and we're waiting to hear back
okay
um but it's there's some boxes that
aren't checked what are those boxes yeah
what are the boxes well in terms of like
space
um
um you know we we kind of with three
girls we wanted them to all have their
own rooms we kind of want to run you
know over 2 000 square foot home and
this is just a little bit smaller
there's no master bathroom it's really
small I'm a bigger guy so I need a
bigger a bigger shower What's it gonna
cost to get What's it gonna cost to
check your boxes because I want to throw
out there when it comes to home buying
there is this idea in the world right
now that it's like my forever home yeah
my dream house and I it's look Ken you
can speak to this I've only owned two
homes and none of them checked every box
well you're never gonna find that I'm
glad you bring that up Brent I think
where she's going and I like where she's
going with this is uh we don't have to
settle for something that we just go
right that but it's better than you know
living on top of each other in the box
of the apartment you're in that you're
about ready to lose your mind uh but I
think what she's saying is right if you
buy a decent house that's a little bit
better than the one you put the offer on
as it relates to like the master bath
and stuff but do the girls all need to
have their own room no that's too much
yeah my boys shared a room for 12 years
of their life my brother and I shared a
room let me be honest with you and they
now have their own room I wish I had put
them back in a room together because
they live like hack mules I mean it's
just disgusting in that room and now
it's two rooms I gotta gripe about you
know let's just be honest I think it's
about you and your wife that's more
important that you all have a good space
yeah I like what Jade's saying what if
we buy a house that's uh this is the 300
or a little bit less but it it's pretty
nice and then it's not the best but we
two three years from now because we paid
cash come on buddy that's what you were
saying yeah and now it becomes a nice
little place to invest exactly this it's
not your forever home you can buy this
one and stay in it for a while and the
market is going to continue to grow and
sell it and move on up you're in a
really great spot or you could buy a
home within your budget right now that
has room to improve and you're willing
to make those improvements and pay cash
over time whether it's adding square
footage or doing all those things that's
what we did Stacy and I are in our third
home here in the national area and each
time uh we have added made changes uh
We've we rode the we rode the market it
did well and we made money we kept
transferring the equity and now we're in
a home Jade and Sam have been there he
doesn't check every box but we got a lot
we got a nice nice house we're very
comfortable there we've added square
footage to it now that house is worth
almost double people well we paid for it
the idea here is some patience yes and
not worry about checking every box I
think the lesson is check the right
boxes yes and what I want to highlight
in this call Brent and for anybody
listening is these are the kind of
problems you want in life where you've
done the money stuff right he's gotten
out of debt he saved up the money he's
he he's done so many things right that
the conversation that we're having is
what's the best way to pay cash for my
house yeah very good I love that that is
amazing so I want to highlight that
you've done such a great job and you've
got great options uh the biggest thing
here is
you know I just want to say that comes
from My Life
um I just want to give her credit by the
way hey congratulations you don't have
the money if you don't have the cash to
pay for it then you shouldn't pay then
you shouldn't buy it you should keep
saying yes ma'am Brent she has got you
into a very nice place my friend
very very very good yeah great call
thanks for the question bro Brent you
got this and I I love the shout out Jade
you're right I mean
I'd pull the offer
I you know I'd pull the offer here and
go let's be a little bit let's be a
little bit more patient I know they're
going stir crazy in the apartment but
he's sitting pretty with 300K sitting in
his bank account waiting for the right
house to pop and Flint don't you think
yeah I get it though I guess he's coming
crazy when we moved here we were in an
apartment a hotel with the two kids and
my husband I was ready to just I could
have lifted that apartment out of its
foundation I had so much frustration I
get it I see where he's at but like hang
on hang on uh because you're sitting
really pretty with that cash great hour
Jade warshaw thank you so much for uh
co-hosting and I want to thank James
Childs and our entire crew behind the
glass for keeping us on the air we want
to thank you America for listening this
is your show this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
guys it's Jade if you love the show and
want a deeper dive on your money Journey
we have a Weekly Newsletter that gives
you trending and helpful articles and
tips on following the Ramsay way just go
to ramsesolutions.com today to sign up
for our newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio this is the
Ramsay show where we help you win with
your money win in your work and win in
your relationships I'm Ken Coleman I'm
joined by Jake warshaw this hour the
phone number for you to jump in and get
your question answered is triple eight
eight two five five two two five that's
triple eight eight two five five two two
five and uh it's tax time Jade and I boy
I'm going to try to get through this
without
saying words that have to be bleeped out
I do not like the taxes uh but we got to
pay them and that means there's a whole
lot of questions about taxes what's
changed from this year to last year all
that stuff we understand that and we
want you to have a better handle on them
so let's pack a question Jade from one
of our listeners I want to roll over my
traditional IRA to a Roth IRA
how do I calculate my tax liability I'm
trying to figure out how much I could
afford to roll over so I don't have too
big of a tax bill what would you tell
well the purpose of converting from a
traditional to a Roth IRA is you want
those after-tax dollars right you want
to be able to pull from that money later
on in life and not have to pay taxes on
it so basically what you're doing is
you're going ahead and paying taxes on
all that money that you put into your
traditional Roth you know you know
before tax dollars and now you got to
pay the taxes on it so it's probably you
know it's going to be Hefty if you got a
lot of money that you're rolling over
absolutely so uh the rollover to the
Roth IRA is a good idea uh you'll pay
that Chunk in taxes now but from here on
out uh your Roth IRA investments will
grow tax-free so uh to learn more about
this issue and get connected to one of
our Pros these are trusted men and women
who we have vetted who understand what
we teach why we teach it and they
understand the tax code they know how to
take care of you head to
ramseysolutions.com taxpro that's
ramseysolutions.com taxpro to get
connected with one of our Ramsey trusted
endorsed like one of our endorsed local
providers and they can guide you through
this so
ramsaysolutions.com slash taxpro and I
will say I have a local tax Pro and
every year I'm grateful for them man
when I can sleep
without stress over on my taxes I don't
want to go to jail I'd look terrible in
one of those jumpsuits
not your color no no so there you go all
right we're gonna get to the phones
let's go to Lynn who joins us in
Wilmington Minnesota Lynn how can we
help
um hi there I've heard about you guys
from my mom yesterday and thank you for
taking my call yeah welcome aboard
what's going on
yeah so um recently my boyfriend and he
had a talk about financial situations
and we had a different opinions about
buying a car or not because his car was
ticking to the auto shop and they
recommend him to buy a new car as soon
as possible and his opinion is buying
the Tesla Model X
which is 43 000 or something and my
opinion is buying a cheap car which is
five or seven thousand because he has
too much debt on his bills how much debt
does he have get some invite
um she has about without the mortgage it
will be roughly about a hundred thousand
K how much how much debt do you have
I don't have any debt okay why are you
why are you guys are you guys living
together are you planning to get married
what's going on because huh yeah so um
we are planning to get married
initially was supposed to be this made
but then he couldn't save money for the
wedding so we kind of pushed it back to
next year I'm raising my hand I'm
raising my hand here because Lynn we
gotta have a I'm gonna have a mama Jade
moment with you
all right or or big sister whatever you
want to go you're surprisingly younger
looking big sister whatever you want to
go with I want to talk to you woman to
woman about this because you have some
smart views about money and you're
you're you have very uh good
instincts when it comes to your money
you have no debt uh you're looking at
these cars and what you're saying makes
perfect sense to the other person here
which is me and I'm going yes Lynn makes
good decisions your boyfriend is not
aligned with you on those good decisions
you and right now let's let's I'm just
calling Spade Spades he's not your
fiance yet
you're still at boyfriend level and
there is I don't want you making
decisions as though you're already
fiance I don't want you making decisions
as though you're already married and
locking yourself mentally into that
because you're not aligned financially
and what I can tell you is if that goes
unchecked this is going to lead to major
problems in the future it's already a
problem now it's already a problem now
and I'm just gonna say this and I know
people listening even you maybe too Lynn
when you're having this kind of
um dissension as a boyfriend girlfriend
it ain't worth it well let's I think
Jade you're right I mean Lynn let's fast
forward for a moment let's assume that
you guys are married okay I want you to
go there with me and he comes home and
tells you this
at the end of the day you guys are
married and so now so now you've assumed
his debt
and he tells you this what is your
reaction if you're married
so um so actually we've been friends for
almost eight years and we've known each
other for quite a long time and when I
come into this relationship I'm willing
to take his dad with me and I'm willing
to
share no no no I appreciate that I
appreciate that that's good I'm asking
you what would be your reaction if you
were his wife and he came home and told
you hey babe the mechanic said I need a
new car and I just uh I just I just
think I'm gonna go with this 43 000
Tesla what would you say to him
yeah we talked about it and I was asking
him why don't you think of buying a used
car which is seven but he doesn't want
to do that yeah that's the problem it
doesn't seem too right to do that and
that's that's what I want to get to you
Lynn don't marry this dude unless unless
he has started to shift his mindset and
go you know what Lynn some of the things
you're saying I want to move towards
that you guys need to have real
conversations about how you view money
not just you saying I think you should
do this and him going oh I don't want to
do that you need to really talk and say
what do you think about debt because I
don't I don't believe in debt and I
don't want to hold debt do you believe
in debt and do you want to hold debt and
are you willing to shift on that because
if you're not we're not aligned and
here's the thing Lynn I get it this is
your dude you've been around him for a
minute if this is not working out
there's somebody better just flat out so
I'm just gonna let you know that I know
it's tough but I am trying to um keep
you from a lifetime of heartache and
frustration yeah that's all I can say
yeah and Lynn I if she's mom and Jade or
sister Jade I'm just this dude over here
who's willing to just shoot it straight
your answer
scares me
I thought that you might go that well if
I had the wife card I'd tell them it
ain't happening and the first thing you
went to is well we were friends for a
long time and now this I think you're
scared to lose this guy you are and
because you're scared to lose him that
you're willing to put up with his
immaturity and his nonsense and Jade is
absolutely 100 correct this will wreck
your life it'll wreck your marriage and
you will end up resenting this guy that
you think you can't live without yeah be
friends if you've been friends for so
long just be friends and and cut the
rest of it loose and go find you a dude
that you align with and you can build
wealth with walk away we might find out
if he values you or the Tesla more
there it is I did it again this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Applause]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
Shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed Perfect Fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by my colleague Jade
warshaw and we are here for you this
hour triple eight eight two five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five five two two five let's go to
Pittsburgh Pennsylvania Tim is on the
line Tim how can we help
guys I'm so glad to have you two instead
of Dave because I know Dave would be
yelling at me before the end of this
conversation
for every time I've heard that
that's the first time it's ever happened
I'd like to pause for a moment because
most of the time it's people telling me
how disappointed they are Dave are you
listening I'm just kidding yeah but Tim
we got you man
Jade has the best laugh it's like blood
pressure medicine it reduces my blood
pressure good wow wow I think I found
your next product there we go tell me a
joke Tim and I'll ease them wait for you
'll be laughing before we're done here
okay oh that's a good shut up
I'm 62 years old 33 years of marriage
just ended oh I'm going I owe my wife 35
000 as part of the divorce agreement
okay and that was because that was to
keep the house my choice was to keep the
house
and that's what they would yell at me
about doing so I'm debt free except for
the house okay I don't have I don't have
much in 401K so I need help determining
from where to draw this 35
000 is you know I'm thinking two or
three things home equity loan my
emergency fund or my 401k so what do you
when do you have to have it is there a
certain time limit that you're
underneath as far as getting her the
knife
90 days okay how much do you have in
your retirement
I'll end up with about 180.
when you say I'll end up what's the
timeline for that
at the end of the divorce I'll have at
the end of the divorce once it's all
split up you'll have 180.
um and is this traditional funds or is
this Roth funds
there are 20 000 in Roth that's all the
rest is traditional 401k
let's see here what do you make what do
you yeah what do you make
right around a hundred thousand all
right what's yours that's another that's
another question when you talk about the
emergency fund of three to six months
there's a big Delta in three to six
months so I mean there's there's sixteen
thousand dollars right there if I go
from six down to three oh there's a okay
really comfortable I don't know Jade May
yell at me on this one but that's I'd
start there uh because we we give you
that rule of thumb that wiggle room and
so if you can come up with 16 by
reducing it from uh six to three uh the
other part I was gonna get at is I
really wanted to know what your if you
got a tight budget because it's just you
now and I'm very sorry uh that your
marriage has come to an end and I don't
want to be insensitive but I'm going to
talk to you man to man right now and
man-to-man I mean uh you got Jade the
grocery expert here I would be living on
nothing and I would be taking as much of
that take-home pay and putting it
towards the 35 so what could you what
could you scrape I mean scrape for in
the next days 90 days how much a month
so you got three months there how much
could you save towards the 35
very very little three thousand maybe
that's not very little that's something
um all right yeah how much is this house
worth
it appraises at 380.
okay
um oh 275 and that's what I figured Dave
would yell at me about and and I will
get out of it in a couple years but I
just need a couple years to get my head
together I'm sorry hold the phone hold
the phone let me go back you said it's
worth 380 and you'll owe 275 so you
paying the 35k for it wasn't like then
you own it free and clear with no debt
so you have to pay 35 Plus then you'll
owe 285.
no no I I I don't I I'm getting confused
so the 35 is basically to buy out her
the equity okay from the 270 to 380 I'm
buying out that Equity basically
I wish you wouldn't have done that is
there any chance to go back on that can
we change that
no it's all signed okay
um
all right I don't I don't know that
you're going to be able to afford to
keep this house I'd sell the house
you're fine I knew that's what Dave
would say I was I was hoping you guys we
all drink the same Kool-Aid so yeah he
made the Kool-Aid I hate to tell you he
started and here's why but like I said I
just want a couple years to fix up some
things maybe make it worth more and help
me I think you're gonna end up if it now
don't get me wrong if this thing is in
shambles you're probably gonna have to
do some things to get it sold but if
it's just you know you're
run-of-the-mill if it if it could be a
turnkey house for someone and you just
wanted to do products or projects for I
wouldn't do that
um the longer that you spend with this I
think the longer you're going to end up
losing out
um sometimes when you've put a lot of
money into something and you've got
money sunk into it you feel like you
need to hold on to it longer because you
don't want to accept it
um in this case Tim with what you've got
in your nest egg and what this what you
would owe on this home I think that you
I don't think that you can keep it I
hate to tell you that because I'm sure
it's a family home it represents
something to you
um but it's like Dave says he talks
about his friend's book uh necessary
Endings by Henry cloud and sometimes
you've got to have a necessary ending to
something
um and you know
I hate to tell you that
and thank you and thank you thank you
for even listening to me because I feel
like you're you're you know I'm sitting
here trying to tell you what to do after
being married you've been married 33
years I've been married 15 you know well
to be fair he called and asked you he
did but uh too I just it's an honor to
even be able to talk with you about this
Tim and I'm sorry about this Tim but
here's the deal uh you already signed
the papers and
um if you sell this I did some quick
math on a 380 uh on 380 380 000 house if
you pay your six percent on that uh if
you I think he said 270 issues what's
your what you owe so you know you're
you're gonna have to look at this as I'm
I'm paying 35 to make
whatever the rest of that is so I don't
know if it's 80 000 quick math or
whatever not a mathematician but the
point is is that you got to get out of
this and putting yourself into a really
tough financial situation to scrape
together 35
000 makes the divorce even worse it's
like insult to injury you know that old
phrase you add insult to injury well
you've been injured and and why pour
salt into that wound with trying to get
out of this you just don't have any
options so I'd sell it and I would make
it a clean break you know go get
yourself a nice little bachelor pad yeah
a part a little condo and and be and and
start building up your finances and and
heal yes and and and move on but this is
you're going to compound the pain yeah
look I mean life looks different now it
is I mean it's Gotta look different now
and it sucks there's nothing about this
Tim that's that's wonderful and you know
we're I feel like we're the bearer of
bad news for you but like you said I
think Dave would have said the same
thing I don't think you can keep this
house and we're pulling for you man yeah
you're listening listen you're fine
you're gonna be okay if you make the
adult decision here there you go it's
tough It's so I just I feel for him
that's that's not easy man I know and
and again
it's what kind of how much pain do you
want to deal with you're already in pain
from the divorce yeah don't add
Financial pain to it I thought when he
first explained it I thought that once
he gave the 3 500 or the 35 000 no the
house was going to be his no money owed
no no
um yeah but once we dug further so yeah
and look look at it this way he's got a
fat emergency fund okay
he's doing good nice apartment save up
money for down payment yeah then he's
not going to feel that that constraint
because if he did that deal he's gonna
feel like he can't breathe and he's
going to have this house and it's going
to be a burden not a blessing no and
that's really where we're at the you
know sometimes the decisions that we
when you guys call in and we have to be
you know the bad cop it's not because we
want to be a bad guy or tell you no or
tell it's because we want to we want you
to avoid more pain yeah we don't want
you to face that pain we want to make it
easier for you
um it's not just because we just I'm
gonna tell you something right now get
high off saying no I've been married
almost 25 years Stacy divorced me I
wouldn't want to live in that house
I don't want a fresh start Too Many
Memories Too Many Memories man there's a
ghost on every corner of that house you
know and so you know what I you know
it's gonna be okay we just want you to
stay financially stable so move forward
Tim better days are ahead so sorry for
your pain but um you're gonna make it
through thanks for the call this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by my colleague Jade
warshaw and we're taking your questions
this hour triple eight eight two five
five two two five triple eight eight two
five five two two five our question of
the day is brought to you by neighborly
your hub for Home Services spring is
here finally and it's time to take care
of those projects that have been on
pause but you don't have to do them
yourself neighborly has the top quality
local service providers in your area
like Mr Handyman Glass Doctor shelf
Genie Precision Door Service and many
more find the help you need to get
started at neighborly.com today all
right today's question comes from Jeremy
from the Ramsay baby steps Community you
can find that on Facebook he says should
I cancel my credit cards as I pay pay
them off or wait until they are paid
down before canceling them I just want
my credit score to go up
all right Jeremy let's let's unpack this
a little bit
um you could go ahead and cancel your
cards today which is what I would do
um if they allow you sometimes they do
make you pay them off first but at the
very very least what you need to do is
cut those Jokers up cut them in half
with some credit cards do what we like
to call a plastic to me and the purpose
of that is to make sure you don't use
them anymore because if you're getting
out of debt let's get out of debt and
make sure that we don't go back so cut
those credit cards up
um sometimes they do make you pay it off
before you can cancel it so if that's
the case then you'll have to wait
um but once they're paid off close the
account never to be seen again but I do
want to talk about this final piece of
this question
um Ken it's just his little tagline here
he says I just want my credit score to
go up yes
um and I want to hit that because if
you're in the baby steps community that
is letting me know that you're
interested in the baby steps and part of
the baby steps guys is we are doing life
different differently whichever you
prefer we have decided that we are going
to pay cash in life and we are not going
to depend on credit and credit scores
because we know that a credit score is
really just an I love debt score it's I
gotta go into debt so I can keep my
credit up and so I can keep my credit up
I got it's it's an endless cycle it is a
game that is rigged and you lose every
time that's right and so let's get into
the habit of just going you know what
yeah when you get out of debt and you
don't owe anybody money and you don't
play the game your credit score will go
down to zero that is not a bad thing it
doesn't go to zero overnight it is a
steady drop and I'll be honest Ken when
I was walking through this with Sam it
is psychologically because we've been
trained to believe that we need credit
it feels it makes you feel some type of
way you're like okay okay I really uh I
feel like I just jumped out of a plane I
hope this parachute works that's the way
it feels but trust I'm telling you from
experience trust and believe your credit
score will eventually drop to zero and a
zero credit score is just as good as a
high credit score you can do all the
things with the zero credit score that
you would have done with a high credit
score the only caveat is you sleep
better because you don't have debt there
it is what a life I like it good case
you know it reminds me of uh it's like
golf the lower the score the better
let's go see this reverse over the rest
of the world and that's where they try
to get you well not a low score kin a
zero score oh I know but I hear what
you're saying you know what it's it's
it's spring Jade looking for chances to
talk about golf come on Don't Rain on My
Parade please all right Esther's up next
in Logan Utah Esther how can we help
hi thanks for having me I'm a big fan oh
it's very nice how can we help
so my husband and I just recently got
married about nine months ago or both in
college I'm in my last semester and he's
just about to start his verse
uh we were gifted FPU for our wedding
and we're in the classes right now and
we will be done with baby step number
three here soon way to go
um thank you thanks yeah it's been
awesome
um
so
um we've been able to build this up a
little bit faster than normal because my
husband and I have a window washing
slash residential cleaning side hustle
very good
um and we project to have an additional
fifteen thousand dollars plus have our
emergency fund done by the end of the
summer
and
um we don't own a home right now my
husband's tuition is paid for in full
because she's a member of the military
and so we're just wondering what do we
do with this money that we have from our
side hustle we'll have about fifteen
thousand dollars so his tuition is paid
for in full well you're do you have any
cost on your tuition
I don't know I'm almost done and I just
pay for it in cash and we get some
federal aid help because we're young and
married so good very good very good so
you basically have 15 000 of money that
you could go into baby step 3B once you
know you said by the by the end of the
summer you'll have your emergency fund
done you'll have 15K extra if you're
looking to buy at any point I'd roll
that money into baby step 3B which is
saving for a down payment
um for your home okay if that's
something that you guys are interested
in doing I don't know if you had any
other plans to travel or you know do
something different but if you're kind
of walking that that path then yeah
start saving up 15K is a great place to
start and just keep keep it rolling what
are your careers going to be when you
get out of school
my husband is doing aerospace
engineering and he wants to commission
as a pilot in the Air Force and I'm
going into marketing so
um another thing along with that is that
we've we
um think that we can get our down
payment covered by the VA by a VA loan
so
I don't know we just like we know that
we won't have to pay for a down payment
um we were thinking of maybe upgrading a
car with that fifteen thousand but we
also realize that that means our largest
asset to our name Will depreciate and so
we don't know if that's the best option
I mean do you need do you need a car or
is it just like what I don't want you to
do is see a pile of money sitting there
and think what do I need to do with this
I need to do something with it
um that's not always the case sometimes
you just got a nice little pile of money
sitting there and that's okay
um you know you can earmark it for
something in the future it doesn't need
to be spent right away typically we
would suggest a conventional loan
um
but it doesn't look like you're really
there yet
um you're you're I don't want to force
you down a route just to give you
something to do does that make sense I
think that you're going to come out of
college you guys are going to be looking
for jobs you're going to find those jobs
just let this money sit keep it in a
high yield savings account make you
three or four percent on it and and just
cool out you guys are doing a great job
um I'm proud of you you're doing great
yep I agree with Jade and just pile more
onto it yeah so we're at fifteen
thousand okay let's just pile more money
up and let's see what life dictates I
listen I can tell you this now you know
I again I'm approaching 25 years of
marriage and and what Stacy and I
thought we would do in our first two
three years of marriage tended out to be
very very different and the plans we had
and I'm sure you would say I could say
the same let me just tell you this uh
you have no idea what life is going to
do and how it's going to twist and turn
and cash is good I'd pile the cash until
you know exactly like it should not be a
situation by the way I'm not in any way
criticizing you Esther but you should
never be in a situation where you're
calling people like us saying what
should I do with this extra cash it
ought to be really clear this is the
thing that we are going to do and we
know why within the right perspective of
what's next in our life and I think for
you guys as you start life together and
you start thinking about building that
life together and I use that word very
intentionally yes uh building a family
growing a family building a home you
know building a lifestyle well there's
some building costs if you know what I'm
saying that is true that's true so very
good Esther yeah just just marinate just
marinate for a while let the juices yeah
get into you so I like that you know
just stack the money in there and have a
little uh have a little cash party once
a month where we get online together
maybe with a little bubbly I like to say
how much money do we have this month
and watch it grow instead of feeling
like you gotta burn it and I think
that's the advice so I love I got to
tell you I love I feel like there's a
bit of theme through the show today
smart people young couples yes I feel
like this is the third instance where
we've had a young couple who are not
drowning yes they're dreaming we yes we
have seen a lot of smart people options
can options what a concept I know I like
it I like it a lot I'll tell you what
else I like we got one more segment to
go people are standing by uh on the
phone lines we got to take care of some
business but don't go anywhere Jade
warshaw Ken Coleman together here on the
Ramsay show we'll be right back
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show Ken
Coleman Jade warshaw with you
today's scripture of the day is James 1
12. blessed is anyone who perseveres
When Trials Come such a person is of
proven worth and will win the prize of
Life the crown that the Lord has
promised to those who love him are quote
of the day Tony Dungy I had the
privilege of interviewing coach Dungey
many years ago a total Prince of a man
okay absolutely great dude he said
Champions don't do extraordinary things
they do ordinary things but they do them
without thinking too fast for the other
team to react excuse me they do them
team to react they follow the habits
they've learned I love that yeah good
stuff there let's go to Lubbock Texas uh
that's where the old Texas Tech Raiders
are uh as if I'm right Lubbock Texas
Melissa is there Melissa how can we help
hello it's an honor to be speaking with
both of you oh thank you how can we help
yeah so I am pregnant from doing June
7th oh wow congratulations
thank you I think you're excited but my
husband is offered a position at a
banking company and training starts on
May 22nd okay and he is required to be
there for seven weeks it's paid training
it's Monday through Friday from 8 A.M
and 5 p.m and he's afraid if he takes it
he won't be there for the baby's birth
is it local training
yes local
so you're afraid that if you go into
labor at 10 A.M
and he's at work they won't allow him to
step away for the birth
yes or if if he ends up leaving either
way they won't accept him back now do we
know this for a fact
we don't we just know that it's really
difficult because I have been trying to
get into the company and I've been
always denied for it I've been trying
for applying five times now and he
finally was able to get in and so we
just assume it's going to be difficult
or okay well okay couple things all
right I thought now correct me if I'm
wrong I thought you said that he's
worried
that he will miss the birth is it he or
is it you or is it both of you or are
you saying hey take the job man what
where are we stand on yeah
so I think of it more as him
preparing us for the future and our just
be in birth and have the baby and he'd
be back and he's like thinking ahead and
he's thinking more like he's exchanging
that experience for money yeah he's not
he misses it he's not
um but I'm gonna answer this I'll let
Jade weigh in I think it'd be great to
get a man's perspective and a female
perspective but if I'm talking to him
man-to-man I'm gonna go look dude first
of all
I can't conceive
I can't conceive it doesn't mean that
it's not real but I can't conceive of a
reality where he gets the job he goes
through the training he's been in
training for a couple of weeks and you
go into labor and he tells them what's
going on that they're going to go well
man I tell her to call her real quick
and tell her to hold on until 5 30. that
would be terrible we would be jerks yeah
I can't conceive of that all right now
when you first started asking the
question
I was wondering if he was going to be
away which is why my first response was
is this local I cannot imagine that they
wouldn't say go be with your wife okay
um but can I just tell you with no
evidence at all
I think it's going to work out
and I think he should take the job
and if for some reason these people
won't let him get to the hospital I
don't think it's something that he
should uh that that he should worry
about I think at that moment if they
don't let him then we walk and you go be
with the birth of the baby and he's
there and we figure something out
because you don't work for people like
that anyway Jade am I right look let me
tell you I I know I I just leave in
anyway I'm not the career person can but
I can't imagine like you said I can't
imagine a place being like no you got to
stay here and fill out this worksheet
until eight you know whatever right if
that if that happened I would tell that
job to get to step in that's my point no
I mean there's no chance that he's going
to miss your baby being born do you
understand what I'm saying
and yes it's just that we have less than
a hundred dollars in the bank and we
don't have any savings and then we're
also 20 000 in debt so he's afraid of
losing any income well I still think
we're operating in a place of fear with
no
we haven't even asked yet yeah first of
all you guys find out that's right so he
needs to just first of all he's working
right now yes
yes okay when does he have to tell them
that he's taking the job is it is it
waiting on his formal signature or
acceptance
uh they told him that he he just had to
do a background check and that they
would he could go in on May 22nd to
start training okay so May 22nd is when
he would officially start the training
yes so when would he leave his current
job to start that training presumably
the same day or what
I mean I mean day the week before
yeah okay these are two different issues
he needs to be working a second job
right now
he needs to be
schlepp encounters at the grocery store
all night to get more money in the bank
because baby's on the way we have two
separate things here but once they do
the background check and they clear him
and say we want you he needs to go great
I'm in
can I throw out a second thought here of
course I'm just going by I don't know a
whole lot about Corporate America but
when I came to work here there's
onboardings regularly yes so if he can't
make it to that onboarding can he say my
wife is having a baby this is her due
date you either can we be flexible that
when the baby is born I can go or can we
do the onboarding sooner is there a room
to negotiate that well you know you
don't have to negotiate I'm glad you
brought it up Jade uh because I was
going a different direction of we're
worried about the wrong things but to
Jade's point when they actually offer
him the job he needs to say hey I'm
happy to take it FYI
sometime in the middle of the training
presumably my wife who is great with
child is going to give birth just want
to make you guys aware and he's just
doing it as a normal human thing and if
they go well no wait a second partner uh
you're not going to be able to leave the
training because about that time is when
we train you how to do TPS reports if
they start doing that then keep in mind
he's not left his previous job
so I'm glad you brought that up it's
good this is a normal thing we need to
reveal and if at that point they go well
that's unacceptable he goes oh well then
he take this job and shove it and I'm
now is it the voice they got you I mean
you went into straight like Yosemite Sam
yeah I mean who's gonna say that but if
they say it Melissa then we've now we've
dodged a bullet because these are bad
people to work for do you understand
what I'm saying absolutely and Melissa
he's not interrupted his income he's not
going to quit his current job until he
signed on for the new job he's not going
to quit the job and sign on until he
goes oh by the way
it's like as he's signing it oh yeah
right hey guys this guy oh I should
probably tell you somewhere in this
trading event and then just let it lay
and then they're going to respond the
right way or the wrong one yeah it could
be open communication that's the best
thing you can do in throughout the job
process all the way up until the very
end just be open honest tell them what's
going on tell them the thing you're
struggling with tell them just be open
now Melissa
uh yes you both need to get busy you
need to sell some stuff you need to cut
some expenses yeah he needs to go bust a
couple of odd jobs work a second or
third job and you need to put about four
or five grand in the bank before baby
gets here and you can easily do that am
I right absolutely and start looking
around the house for things to sell you
might have something that you can
offload and get you a couple of hundred
dollars anything that you can do because
my guess is there's going to be a
deductible involved here that you're
going to need to pay and I need to run
this by you what's up I think a baby
gift is in order what do you think we
should give them to help them pay off at
22 000 in debt let's do Financial Peace
University Austin is going to pick up
after uh we're finished with this call
and he's going to offer that to you now
I want you both to go through it and
it's going to give you all the tools
that you need going forward having a
baby it's a lot going on you've got the
debt you're trying to pay off financial
piece is going to give you the tools
that you need the confidence that you
need you're going to learn everything
you need to know to make good choices
with money and develop great habits with
your money so that you can build wealth
and be able to to give and live the life
that that you love yay so there you go
Melissa thank you so much you're welcome
for you do we know if it's a boy or a
girl
it's a girl oh tell us the name real
quick
Melody Melody I love it hey it's so
awesome I love my babies me too uh she
sounded like a baby yeah she's young
she's I love it another young couple
making a good start I love it hang on
the line Melissa will get you your baby
gift and we're so excited for you guys
Jade warshoff fantastic show thank you
so much fun to be with you my friend
James Childs and the crew thank you guys
for keeping us on the air and to you
America we do this for you because it is
your show this is the Ramsay show
hey it's Ken if you like what you heard
in this episode and want to know more
about getting started on the Ramsey Baby
Steps go to ramsesolutions.com and click
on the get started button we'll help you
figure out the best next step for you
based on your specific situation again
that's ramsesolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]